Rectangle ABCD is drawn
in the coordinate plane.
The edges of the rectangle are as follows,
and the tokens are also given us.
At these given coordinates, what is the length
on the AD side of this rectangle?
So let's just put it on.
This is one way to solve.
Let's see, they're all in fact
in the first quadrant,
so I can focus on the first quadrant.
Let's say this is the axis.
This is the axis and let me also draw the x axis.
Ax x and I really want to focus
on points A and D,
because we have to find the length of the country alone
from point A to point D.
So, point A, let me do it with another color.
Point A is equal to seven,
y is equal to one.
One two three four,
five, six, seven, this is equal to seven.
y is equal to one.
y is equal to one, so here is point A.
Point A, let me mark it. Point A.
Then where is D?
Point D has exactly the same x coordinate,
but its y coordinate is slightly higher.
Its y coordinate equals six. She is actually five higher.
So point D is equal to seven,
y is equal to six.
So, y is equal to one, two, three,
four, five, and six.
That is, y is equal to six
and so we can draw the point.
It will be right here.
This is point D
and in fact we could link them to a stretch if we want,
to show that this is a rectangle.
Let me draw it. I can just draw it this way.
And we already have it.
Even the whole rectangle has not yet been drawn,
I just brought these two points,
and we can think about what length AD is.
We can say that x does not change, going from A to D,
but we increase in the direction of five.
We go from y equal to one, to y equal to five,
to y is equal to six.
So the change in t is equal to five.
So what is the length of this stretch?
Well she will be five.
It will be five, no matter what the units are.
This is the length of side AD.
She will be equal to five.
We went from the point (7; 1)
to the point (7; 6).
It is said to us that this is a rectangle.
And just for our satisfaction
we can draw the entire rectangle.
We have this point B, which is equal to five,
equal to one, so let me draw it.
I am doing this now only for pleasure.
We're ready for the task.
So, equal to five, equal to one. That's right here.
This is point B.
Let me write Q. This is the point (5; 1).
And then we have the point C. I'll do it in another color.
Point C is equal to five, equal to six.
x equal to five, equal to six.
Point C is right here.
Point C is the point x equal to five equal to six.
And then we can tie all the points if we want,
and clearly see that this is a rectangle.
I can connect these.
I can connect these two.
Then I can connect these two.
And then we see that we really have a rectangle.
But we've already answered that length a little bit ago
on side AD is equal to five.
If we were interested in other countries,
the length of BA, but that's two.
a difference of two along the x direction,
the horizontal direction,
a difference of five in the direction t.
We go from equals to one to six.
So we got it.
We actually found all the countries
of this rectangle.